[Music]
there is a curse that has plagued
humanity since ancient times the Greeks
fought it by chewing aromatic resins
while the Chinese resorted to eggshells
in the ancient jewish talmud it's even
considered legal grounds for divorce
this horrible scourge is halitosis
otherwise known as bad breath but what
causes it and why is it so universally
terrifying
well think of some of the worst odours
you can imagine like garbage
pleaselet or rotting meat all of these
smells come from the activity of
microorganisms particularly bacteria and
as disgusting as it may sound similar
bacteria live in the moisture-rich
environment of your mouth don't panic
the presence of bacteria in your body is
not only normal it's actually vital for
all sorts of things like digestion and
disease prevention but like all living
things bacteria need to eat the bacteria
in your mouth feed off of mucous food
remnants and dead tissue cells in order
to absorb nutrients through their cell
membranes they must break down the
organic matter into much smaller
molecules for example they'll break
proteins into their component amino
acids and then break those down even
further into various compounds some of
the foul-smelling byproducts of these
reactions such as hydrogen sulfide and
cadaverine escape into the air and waft
their way towards unsuspecting noses our
sensitivity to these odors and
interpretation of them as
smells maybe an evolutionary mechanism
warning us of rotten food and the
presence of disease
smell is one of our most intimate and
primal senses playing a huge role in our
attraction to potential mates in one
poll 59% of men and 70% of women said
they wouldn't go on a date with someone
who has bad breath which may be why
Americans alone spend 1 billion dollars
a year on various breath products
fortunately most bad breath is easily
treated the worst smelling byproducts
come from RAM negative bacteria that
live in the spaces between gums and
teeth and on the back of the tongue by
brushing and flossing our teeth using
antibacterial mouthwash at bedtime
gently cleaning the back of the tongue
with a plastic scraper and even just
eating a healthy breakfast we can remove
many of these bacteria and their food
sources in some cases these measures may
not be enough due to dental problems
nasal conditions or rarer ailments such
as liver disease and uncontrolled
diabetes behaviors like smoking and
excessive alcohol consumption also have
a very recognizable odor regardless of
cause the bad smell almost always
originates in the mouth and not the
stomach or elsewhere in the body but one
of the biggest challenges lies in
actually determining how our breath
smells in the first place and it's
unclear why it may be that were to
acclimatized to the smell inside our own
mouths to judge it and methods like
cupping your hands over your mouth or
licking and smelling your wrists and
don't work perfectly
either one studies showed that even when
people do this they tend to rate the
smell subjectively according to how bad
they thought it was going to be but
there's one simple if socially difficult
way of finding out how your breath
smells just to the breath
[Music]
you
[Music]